numpy and scipy are two essential
libraries in the Python Programming
ecosystem and while both are used for
math type things there are both
fundamental differences and areas of
overlap between them so let's get into
what they are how they can be
differentiated and then some use cases
so numpy numpy is an abbreviation it's
an abbreviation for
numerical
python
numpy numerical python it lets you do
stuff with numbers now numpy light works
with large multi-dimensional arrays and
matrices along with a large collection
of high-level mathematical functions to
operate on these arrays
multi-dimensional arrays you say what
are those well you can think of
multi-dimensional arrays as lists of
lists or even lists of lists of lists
in essence a one-dimensional array
that's something like this
it's a it's a simple row of items like a
row of numbers then you have a
two-dimensional array that's like this
and you can think of that as being like
a table where you have multiple rows
Each of which may contain multiple items
now this can go even further we can have
three-dimensional array this
four-dimensional array you get the idea
now consider a real life application
like 3D Graphics modeling you might have
a three-dimensional array representing
the X the Y and the Z coordinates of
each point in a 3D model or think about
time series data where one axis
represented chronological order of data
these multi-dimensional arrays are also
called tensors and they're fundamental
to a lot of the heavy number crunching
required it feels like physics
mathematics and machine learning with
numpy you can perform operations on
these arrays as if they were regular
numbers and numpy handles all the
complexity of manipulating these data
structures but that's just that's just
scratching the surface of what numpy is
capable of with the help of numpy you
can perform mathematical operations so
some basic stuff like addition
subtraction or you can do things like
squaring on an element
you can perform statistical operations
like calculating the mean the median and
the standard deviation of your data so
that's numpy numerical python
PSI pi
that stands for
scientific
python
and and it's not as if it's a competing
library to numpy which is just as well
given that it clearly has a better name
PSI pi
you see scipy is actually built on top
of numpy
scipyte leverages numpy arrays and
extends its capabilities now what does
this mean in practice well it means that
scipy can do everything that numpy can
do and more some scipy uses the array
data structure from numpy and enhances
it adding further functionality for more
complex and mathematical and scientific
Computing tasks so it's kind of like a a
numpy plus
so in essence if you're using scipy
you're also using numpy but the focus on
sci-fi really is on scientific Computing
and that means support for routines like
numerical integration interpolation
things like optimization things like
linear
algebra and things related to statistics
and while some functions can only be
performed in scipy
there are overlapping capabilities so
take for example interpolation which
involves estimating unknown values that
fall between known values both numpy and
scipy have support for this but there
are key differences so let's illustrate
this with a simple example so suppose we
have a set of known data points like
we've got here and we want to estimate
the values at new points that fall
between the known data so parts around
here
now with with numpy we can perform what
is called a simple linear
a simple linear interpolation and that
uses the NP dot enter P function now
this involves fitting a straight line
between each pair of known points so
like this
and using this to estimate the unknown
values it's quick it's efficient and
it's often good enough for simple use
cases
SCI Pi's interpolation capabilities
though they go far beyond this so for
example
using scipy we can support something
called cubic
interpolation or specifically cubic
spline interpolation
now how this works is a little bit
different it involves fitting a smooth
curve through unknown data points so it
look more
like something like deaths
and this can provide a more accurate
estimate of the unknown values
especially when data has a complex
non-linear structure
numpy's interpolation is straightforward
and it's efficient Cyprus is more
flexible and sophisticated
so
where are the libraries typically used
well let's say you're working in data
science exploring a large data set to
find patterns and insights with numpy
you can quickly perform operations like
calculating the mean or standard
deviation of your data filtering for
specific values or transforming and
reshaping your data numpy's capabilities
are also well suited to image processing
so uh let's take a beautifully drawn
image like this
images can be represented as
multi-dimensional arrays like this
and here those multimeter dimensional
arrays are the dimensions corresponding
to say height width and color channels
and with numpy you can manipulate these
arrays to apply filters Transformations
and other image processing operations
now on the other hand when you work
requires more advanced and specialized
mathematical or scientific functionality
that's when PSI Pi comes into play take
for example the field of signal
processing scipy has a suite of
functions in its signal module for
Signal processing so here's a signal
and we can for example use its fast
Fourier transform functions or F
f t
and what that can do is is it can
convert the signal from the time domain
into the frequency domain and that will
let you analyze the signals for
different frequency components so that
might look something like a bar chart
format like this
if you're designing an aircraft wing and
you need to find the shape that
minimizes drag while satisfying
constraints like maximum weight and
material strength you could use the
optimization routines in scipy to solve
this problem
and look one key point that underpins
the use of both of these libraries is
their efficiency both numpy and scipy
are designed to manage computational
resources efficiently and that means
they handle large data sets and perform
complex operations while minimizing the
usage of your computer's memory and
processing power that's one of the
reasons why they're a go-to choice for
number crunching tasks in short if
you're working in a field that involves
data analysis or scientific computation
chances are you'll be using numpy
scipy or both
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like And subscribe thanks for watching